hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter three of his work on liberty
john stuart mill
makes a seeming excursis
into some discussion of theology
specifically
that of what he calls the calvinist
theory and he's
mostly interested here in the effects on
individuality and its development
it comes up when he says it is so on the
calvinist theory and what does he mean
what what is so
well the question is is this or is it
not the desirable condition of human
nature
and we can say well what what is the
desirable condition of human nature that
he's talking about
if we backtrack just a little bit he
says
we can look at uh in our times from the
highest class of society
down to the lowest everyone lives as if
under the eye of a hostile and dreaded
censorship not only in what concerns
others but what concerns only themselves
the individual or the family do not ask
themselves
what do i prefer or what would suit my
character in disposition or
what would allow the best and highest in
me to have fair play
and enable it to grow and thrive they
ask themselves
instead what is suitable to my position
what is usually done by persons of my
station
and pecuniary circumstances or were
still what is usually done by persons of
a station in circumstances
superior to mine and he says i don't
mean
that they choose what is customary in
preference to what suits their own
inclination
it does not occur to them to have any
inclination
except for what is customary and so
what's going on here what is the the
effect he says that they have no nature
to follow their human capacities are
withered and starved
they become incapable of any strong
wishes or native pleasures
and are generally without either
opinions or feelings of home growth or
properly their own and he concludes this
by saying now is this
or is it not the desirable condition of
human nature
and the calvinist says yes
a hundred times yes to that now
what does mill actually mean by
calvinism here
is he only talking about those
protestant christians
who self-identify as followers of john
calvin
for example the presbyterians of his
time
the remnants of the independents such as
the puritans who
largely went over to the united states
the french
huguenots is that what he he means
no he has something broader in mind here
as we can see by the way that he's going
to
describe their attitude
i would go so far as to say that within
many different
protestant denominations and within
you know the catholic church orthodox
churches
eastern oriental churches you know
the entire gamut of christianity we can
find
people endorsing something like this
calvinist
theory they might have been you know on
the outs with with their particular
church or they may have been sort of
looked up
as an ideal or exemplar of sainthood for
their church but there's a lot of people
who do adopt a similar position to what
he's calling the calvinist here
and i would go so far as to say even
further
that we can find similar tendencies
towards asceticism towards
expergating the human nature in favor of
obedience to the divine
in other religions as well and
we might even be able to say that we can
find this
in secular forms although i'll leave
that for you
to think about as a further reflection
so what is the calvinist theory mill
sums it up by saying that it views the
one great offense of humankind
as being self-will as
choosing for itself outside
of what we might call the brackets or
limitations
of obedience to the divine will and and
essentially the choice is you choose
your own way
you choose self-will or you choose
god's will and aligning yourself with
that
and so from this point of view as he
says
all the good of which humanity is
capable is comprised
in obedience obedience to
god's plan god's will however it's been
revealed however it's understood
and so any bit of asserting your own
self-will that's not entirely within
those
those confines is going to be something
bad something diabolical something
corrupt something
evil you could say and so the calvinist
in this sense views uh human nature
as radically corrupt like he says there
is no redemption
for anyone until human nature is killed
within him and the corollary to this
is that he says holding this theory of
life
uh crushing out any of the human
faculties capacities
and susceptibilities is no evil
man needs no capacity but that of
surrendering himself to the will of god
if he uses any of his faculties for any
other purpose but
but to do that supposed will more
effectually he is better
without them so if we take the sort of
things that mill typically talks about
developing the moral sense in a
progressive way
to the point where we might say well
we've been treating people
badly we need to rectify that within
society
the calvinist would say who are you to
interfere
with the divine and natural order
who are you to rely upon your conscience
your reasoning capacities to say that we
should do something differently
in society or if the calvinists aren't
in charge of course
then they always want to change society
it's part of how the puritans
got themselves kicked out of england
right
but you know the idea here is that the
human capacities and faculties are
only there to serve god
and to align the human being in relation
to that
another thing that mill often talks
about are our aesthetic
faculties our capacities to grasp beauty
to understand artwork to produce
and you know the the calvinist could say
okay
produce but for the greater glory of god
anything else
is self-will let's get rid of all those
renaissance paintings
that are showing the artistry of the
artist uh and just focus
on the things that are you know aligned
perfectly
with the divine so we can think about
all sorts of other
examples mill also says that this can
come in what he calls a
mitigated form by people who wouldn't
call themselves
calvinists right but they're really
calvinist
at heart in a certain way he calls this
a less ascetic
viewpoint of the will of god so that
there's a little bit of
wiggle room a little bit of fun time
built into it he
says here that they they have um they
assert his will to be that mankind
should gratify
some of their inclination so you don't
just expunge everything
you know maybe you can drink beer but
only uh
you know to benefit your health or to
at certain occasions for conviviality
but you can only have three
and we we see this sort of thing done
in many religious communities and then
people immediately find ways to
sneak around and and get what they want
right which then from a calvinist
interpretation is
is evil he says that they're allowed to
gratify
some of their inclinations not in the
manner they themselves prefer but in the
way
of obedience that is in a way prescribed
to them by
authority therefore by the necessary
conditions of the case
the same for all so somebody comes in
and says
all right you can indulge yourself to a
certain extent
but only to this extent and only for
these reasons
and only with these desires in mind
and anything else is bad so let's all be
like this
together or you know you don't have to
indulge yourself you can be more
aesthetic
but you can't be less ascetic
than what we're laying out here so
what is the the net effect of this well
you know it's gonna
keep people within very close limits and
their individuality is not going to
develop except perhaps by way of
rebellion against that
mill thinks that this is contrary to a
proper
understanding of the divine being and in
saying this
he is echoing many many religious people
throughout the history of christianity
and the other great world religions as
well
saying that religion
should recognize that the divine being
is a being who's good
who wants us to develop as human beings
who gave us the
potentialities and the capacities and
the faculties not in order that they be
so neatly pruned that they're almost
like a
uh over wrought garden you know where
the the topiary
is carved you know has been cut and
pruned
into the shape of swans or something
like that and a bush can't actually be a
bush
right or where you have to constantly
plant and replant and pull things out
because
the color scheme has to be just right no
mill thinks that what we want is you
know something more like
a real biome that develops he doesn't
use those terms of course but
you could think of it in those terms
where you know
here in the midwest for example the
prairie grasses are not actually
weeds neither are necessarily dandelions
which are
one of the hardiest of the plants and
have a beautiful flower and can be used
for many things so according to mill
what god really would want from us
is for our faculties to be as he says
cultivated and unfolded and that's going
to require
deviating from the calvinist viewpoint
on things we're not going to be able to
buy into something like that he says
that
many persons no doubt sincerely think
human beings cramped and dwarfed are as
the maker designed them to be
just as many have thought trees are a
much finer thing when clipped into
pollards
but if it'd be any part of religion to
believe that man was made by a good
being
it's more consistent with faith to
believe
that these faculties are to be
cultivated not
rooted out and consumed and that he the
the divine being takes delight in every
nearer approach
made by his creatures to the ideal
conception embodied in them
every increase in any of their
capacities of comprehension
of action or enjoyment and here he says
something really interesting
he says there's a different type of
human excellence
from the calvinistic a conception of
humanity
as having its nature bestowed on it for
other
purposes than merely to be abnegated he
brings up
pagan self-assertion now this is
something that was a contrast back then
at the time that mill was writing
paganism you could think about
aristotle and the great souled person
the prideful person
who is indeed worthy of great honors
demands them
and then the christian ideal which seems
to be
at odds with this christianity says
pride self-will
is a fundamental
problem it's a it's a stumbling block
it's something that actually can vitiate
or destroy all the other virtues as it
sucks them
in mill says it's not so
simple as that he goes on and says
pagan a self-assertion is one of the
elements of human worth there's
something good to that as well as
christian self-denial
there is a greek ideal of
self-development in which the
the platonic and christian ideal of
self-government blends with
but does not supersede and then he has
some comparisons here
it may be better to be a john knox a
famous calvinist
who brought calvinism to scotland than
to be in
alcibiades alcibiades if you don't know
who he was
a student and lover of socrates who
was kind of the golden boy of athens at
the time and turned out to be a complete
screw-up and
betrayed athens sparta and persia in
turn
and ruined his life and and that of many
other people
so he says it's better to be john knox
than to be alcibiades but those aren't
the only
options it is better to be a pericles
than either nor would a pericles
if we had one in these days be without
anything good
which belonged to john knox so what we
want is something which
interfuses these different aspects in
other places for example
utilitarianism mill will say that we
need to
borrow from all these different things
not just
you know christianity but also stoicism
to a certain extent and also from this
and that
in order to have a better character and
that's only possible if you
have the freedom and not just the
freedom
in terms of people not censoring you but
the freedom in terms of people not
getting on your backs about you being a
bad
person for following your inclinations
if you have the freedom to consider
to appropriate to try on to incorporate
into what he calls your individuality
you